tensions are rising in Catalonia an
independence referendum is planned for
October the first and if the majority
vote YES the Catalan government says it
will declare independence from Spain we
are ready to do it we have the
determination to do it now remember is a
member of the Catalan Parliament which
favors independence a parliament set on
a collision course with the Spanish
government in Madrid like I said aspire
todos los españoles Javier albiol is the
leader of the catalan branch of Spain's
ruling Peoples Party his party fiercely
opposes the referendum that has been
deemed illegal by the Spanish
Constitutional Court police have raided
Catalan government offices seized ballot
papers and arrested at least 12
officials in a bid to stop the vote
[Music]
catalonia has been a part of spain since
the country first emerged as a unified
Kingdom in 1469 famous for its
spectacular human towers a tradition
dating back to the 18th century
Catalonia is one of Spain's wealthiest
regions incorporating the tourist hub of
Barcelona and a thriving manufacturing
industry it already enjoys more
self-government than almost any other
European region so why are so many
Catalans discontented with their lot
pro-independence supporters claim
catalonia is robbed by Spain the gap
between what Catalans pay in taxes and
what they get back and Services is 10
billion euros per year that's around 4
percent of catalonia's GDP is there a
problem of taxing collection in
Catalonia no there is not
so what is the problem there because
they are the public resources but if the
reserves are not used to improve the
quality of life of the people then there
is a problem in the middle Spain's
financial crisis and the austerity that
followed fuelled the pro-independence
movement who claim that catalonia would
be much better off on its own but in
many countries the wealthy regions prop
up the poorer ones opponents of
Independence say that being part of a
bigger country will make everyone better
off by itself became a soccer field ok
mass was posted Allah ho esta creando en
una a percussion director positiva in
favour the de Catalunya port olisar
momentos some dollars by Unidos somos
war appears on the general Franco's
dictatorship Catalan could not be used
in any official context since democracy
was restored in 1978 the language has
rebounded a 2001 census found that
Catalan was spoken by 75% of the
population and it is now the main
language in the region schools but in
2010 the Spanish courts rejected a
change to the Constitution that would
have given the catalan language
preferential status many Catalans viewed
this as an insult and it strengthened
pro-independence feel
first of all we're Democrats which means
that when we demand to be treated as a
mature society we mean this when we
demand that the opinion of the people
who's taking into account win in this
catalonia's pro-independence leaders
claim that the referendum is a
democratic right Madrid's refusal to
acknowledge this infuriates them the
ruling coalition was voted into power in
2015 and the promise of a referendum and
now they feel they have a mandate it was
a clear result 72 MPs were elected
defending the idea catalonia should be a
state that's a huge majority of the
catalan parliament which is 135 and
peace well for the first time we have a
clear majority in the parliament
defending that opinion nationalists say
they have a mandate but it's
questionable although they gained 53
percent of the seats in parliament they
won only 48% of the popular vote and
opinion polls show that 71 percent of
the population went to referendum but
only 41% are likely to vote yes toda las
encuestas Sanderlin cannot sustain a
malaria in the mucho menos and favor de
la guerra independent via the PC
Castillo ticket system sentimiento the
Karuna suspect of tienen que measure are
the new moon caso a sentiment
independentista it's my oratory or the
Catalan government is hell-bent on
proceeding with the referendum setting a
precedent for other regions such as the
Basque Country to follow with regional
and state government set to collide
head-on on October 1st the unity of
Spain hangs in the band
[Music]
you